un climat délétère s'est installé au
liban depuis quelques jours le pays est
secoué par de violentes manifestations
notamment à tripoli
plusieurs banques ont été incendiés ou
saccagés les libanais protestent depuis
octobre 2019 contre la classe politique
accusée de corruption et d'incompétence
face à la crise économique
une colère amplifiée avec les mesures
mises en place pour enrayer la
propagation du coronavirus l'économie
est à l'arrêt avec la fermeture des
commerces et des restaurants
à cela s'ajoute la dégringolade de la
livre libanaise dans les bureaux de
change
bien sûr la pauvreté va créer ce genre
de situation tant que nous avons des
dirigeants qui ne se préoccupe pas du
peuple
chacun ainsi dans leur maison ne
s'adressant pas et on n'est donc pas la
population tant que le gouverneur de la
banque centrale est encore en poste et
cette situation va certainement
s'aggraver
nous avons atteint le stade où les gens
n'en peuvent plus la fin est en train de
tuer des gens
que ce soit à cause de l'augmentation
continue du taux de change du dollar ou
de l'augmentation des prix des denrées
alimentaires
aujourd'hui quand vous entrez dans un
supermarché avec cinquante mille livres
libanaises
vous ne repartez qu'avec quelques
articles une personne qui gagnait 1
millions de livres libanaises est
désormais payé 200 dollars américains
face à cette contestation de plus en
plus virulent que le gouvernement
libanais a adopté un vaste plan de
réformes
il prévoit une croissance positive dès
2022 une réduction de la dette publique
à moins de 100 % du pib et un budget
excédentaire à partir de 2024
pour cela le liban espère compter sur
l'appui des pays bailleurs de fonds qui
ont promis 11 milliards de dollars en
2018 mais aussi sur le fmi auprès duquel
ils espèrent obtenir 10 milliards de
dollars
l'état dispose désormais d'une feuille
de route claire pour la gestion des
finances publiques
aujourd'hui je peux dire que nous sommes
sur la bonne voie pour sortir le liban
de la profonde crise financière le liban
cherchera à obtenir un soutien financier
de plus de 10 milliards de dollars en
plus des fonds de la conférence cèdera
une croissance économique positive sera
rétablie à partir de 2022
aujourd'hui tous les indicateurs sont
dans le rouge
la dette atteint 92 milliards de dollars
soit 170 % du pib et le déficit
budgétaire tourne autour de 10 %
le gouvernement doit maintenant
convaincre les libanais de l'efficacité
de ces réformes
le président michel aoun a convoqué les
chefs des blocs parlementaires à une
réunion mercredi prochain pour leur
exposer le plan de sauvetage